burkina faso lucha por revertir la
amenaza yihadista en el país y se
enfrenta una ardua batalla desde hace
siete años los grupos terroristas
asociados al qaeda y al estado islámico
se han extendido por los vecinos Mali y
níger Estableciendo un reinado de terror
tras atentar la embajada francesa el
cuartel general del ejército hoteles y
restaurantes en la capital wagabú los
yihadistas han atacado principalmente
las zonas Rurales del Norte y el este
del país en junio del año pasado un
atentado en el pueblo de seite tenga
dejó al menos 86 muertos y el lunes un
convoy de 150 vehículos que transportaba
suministros a la ciudad de givo fue
atacado el gobierno afirma que 11
personas murieron pero los Testigos
dicen que hay decenas de personas
desaparecidas la violencia
intercomunitaria también está muy
presente los enfrentamientos entre los
fulani y los Moshi en la provincia de
San matenga en 2019 dejaron 72 muertos y
6.000 desplazados
desde que se independizó de Francia en
1960 burkina faso ha luchado por
mantener la estabilidad el líder
revolucionario Thomas ankara tomó el
poder en 1983 adoptando políticas de
izquierda pero fue derrocado por bláis
quien continuó gobernando durante 27
años antes de ser de puesto en una
revuelta Popular en 2014
una junta militar está en el poder desde
el 24 de enero tras sublevarse contra el
líder electo Rock caboré prometiendo
expulsar a los yihadistas
principal la seguridad sigue siendo
nuestra principal preocupación debemos
reducir significativamente las zonas
bajo influencia terrorista y los
impactos del extremismo violento y el
extremo pero los ataques terroristas han
seguido más del 40% del territorio de
burkina faso está fuera del control del
gobierno un millón y medio de personas
han sido desplazadas Eso es casi el 10%
de la población del país